what do you think is the most beautiful
thing you've seen alpha zero do oh the
most personally yes so there was
actually
the most beautiful game that i've seen
alpha zero plays is being dubbed the
immortal zogswang game by uh uh
akadamata on the one of youtube
brilliant youtube commentators
uh
uh and he
it was alpha zero playing stockfish
and um sacrificing a load of pieces to
uh get stock fishes all of the
sockfish's major pieces queen and two
rooks stuck in the corner basically
sealed them up like in a tomb
and zugswang means uh
that any move that the player makes will
make their position worse
and um it's never been done to stockfish
before and alpha zero did it super
elegantly through sacrificing
sacrificing pieces yeah it's a beautiful
video online on it and thank you for
giving me and signing this book
you're welcome uh what's what is the
book
the book was written by um the british
chess champion and uh and uh women
international master natasha reagan and
matthew sadler uh and we gave i known
them both for years for my chest days as
a kid and um
when they heard about alpha zero uh
before we released it they they they
wanted to come in and try it out we gave
them full behind-the-scenes access to it
and then um matthew sadler said to me
it's like discovering the notebooks of a
of a of a hidden champion that no one
knew about and he then wrote this book
about all of the different ideas that
alpha zero had and the cool thing is in
there in that book so this is it's a
chess book but also the first few
chapters about about how we built alpha
zero our journey towards it and then
magnus carlsen was one of the first
people we gave the book to
and he uh
he sort of probably said it was very
useful to him and he's incorporated a
lot of the ideas into his own play the
new ideas you could say created by alpha
alpha zero to lex a fellow explorer of
the mysteries of the universe
thomas that thank you so much thank you
very much thank you for everything you
do
you